vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur notre compte
télégramme verte et france vous pouvez
prendre part au débat interpeller nos
invités au sommaire de ce mardi 2
novembre s'accroche toujours sur la
prolongation du pass à lithaire en
france pas de consensus trouvé
aujourd'hui en commission parlementaire
mixte paritaire et débuter le
gouvernement souhaite mettre fin aux qr
codes le 31 juillet hors de question
pour les sénateurs qui préférait le 28
février un désaccord qui vous voulez
voir un nouvel examen du texte ce sera
l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
paul johnson prudemment optimiste sur
les chances de succès de la coop 26 plus
de 80 pays se sont engagés aujourd'hui à
glasgow à réduire les émissions méthane
de 30% d'ici 2030 l'autre gaz à effet de
serre qui réchauffe le climat autre
message fort de la journée celui de
vladimir poutine qui rejoint l'urgence à
agir pour protéger l'ensemble des forêts
joe biden doit lui annoncer ce soir ces
élections ont la planète mais en
attendant les états unis sont toujours
le plus grand pollueur du monde après la
chine
zoom à 21h sur le contrat d'engagement
jeunes nouveau dispositif du
gouvernement français pour répondre à la
précarité des moins de 26 ans sans
formation ni emploi l'enveloppent
pourrait aller jusqu'à 500 euros par
mois condition sinequanone 15 à 20
heures par semaine de formation
d'accompagnement alors ce contrat
d'engagement jeunes dispositif coûteux
de plus ou mesure aura baissé selon le
débat est ouvert et les habits d'hiver
j'en attend d'ailleurs vos réactions
donc sur le conte telegraph d'ayrté
france
députés et sénateurs ne sont donc pas
parvenus à un accord aujourd'hui sur la
prolongation du pass sanitaire alors que
l'on assiste à une recrudescence de
l'épidémie en france la querelle
politique en commission mixte paritaire
s'est cristallisée sur la date de forme
cette mesure on retrouve notre reporter
david kelly fin à l'assemblée nationale
vont se voir davies alors au coeur des
discussions houleuses le recours de
ronco pas sanitaire jusqu'au 28 février
contre le 31 juillet date voulue par le
gouvernement
effectivement la commission a s'est
achevée vers 14h36 hier à l'assemblée
nationale
aucun compromis aucune issue n'a été
trouvée à l'issue de cette commission
mixte paritaire ce qui va se passer
maintenant pour le texte et bien c'est
un nouvel examen dès ce soir au sein de
l'hémicycle et demain est le texte ira
ensuite au sénat jeudi avant un ultime
putt au palais bourbon ce vendredi
écoutez yezh bruz vivait là président de
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
le point d'achoppement portait sur la
date le sénat souhaitait qu'il y ait un
échéance en février 2022 et nous nous
considérions qu'il ne fallait pas fixer
un terme aussi court au gouvernement
dans l'utilisation de certains outils de
vigilance sanitaire et qu'il avait
besoin compte tenu de ce que nous disent
tous les épidémiologistes et tous les
autorités sanitaires que le gouvernement
avait besoin de plus longtemps nous ce
que nous avons appris cette épidémie
c'est qu'il faut garder de la souplesse
dans l'ue que dans l'utilisation des
outils qu'il faut qu'il soit adapté et
proportionné évidemment
largement remaniée par le sénat les
versions textes sont beaucoup de poids
est différente le principal point
d'achoppement vous l'avait dit et vous
l'avez entendu dans lé mot de riels
brawn pie v eh bien elle se cristallise
sur la date de fin du recours au pass
sanitaire fin juillet pour les députés
de la majorité fin février pour les
sénateurs mais aussi pour certains un
député de l'opposition
écoutez
gouvernement avait briefé la majorité
pour qu'elles refusent en tête les
avancées qui avait été faite au sénat de
ne pas donner les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement d'en haut niveau sanitaire
jusqu'en juillet 2022 qu'il y ait au
moins une revoyure au mois de février
2022 ça me semblait quand même la
moindre des choses puisqu'on demande aux
parlementaires de se dessaisir de leur
pouvoir pour le donner aux gouvernements
or nous sommes nous nous avons la
parcelle de pouvoir que le peuple nous a
confié on ne peut pas s'en dessaisir
comme ça sans regarder les mesures c'est
pas possible il ya bien sûr ce problème
qui consiste à ce que les chefs
d'établissement des écoles puissent
regarder le statut des enfants et là
c'est un coin de plus enfoncée dans le
secret médical on a une majorité en
marche qui s'obstine à refuser que sur
la question du pass sanitaire que sur la
question de la territorialisation des
mesures c'est à dire adapter les mesures
en fonction de la réalité sanitaire ou
bien encore la décision de transférer au
directeur d'école le sco en contrôler si
les gamins sont non vaccinés ce qui est
contraire au secret médical sur tous ces
sujets là qui sont fondamentaux la
majorité refuse le débat et refuse de
vote se passent sanitaire n'a aucun
intérêt puisque aujourd'hui on sait que
même vacciné on peut transmettre
donc ça n'a aucun sens ce pas sanitaire
est une fausse protection et même
dangereux parce que les gens atténue les
gestes barrière se croyant protégés et
ne le sont pas donc moi je veux la
suppression du pass sanitaires je veux
la gratuité des tests pour que on évite
une nouvelle augmentation de l'épidémie
et qu'on puisse tester car la meilleure
protection c'est le test les gestes
barrière savoir se protéger la prudence
c'est de refuser le pass sanitaire en
vérité à savoir que ce projet de loi a
créé de réelle dissensions au sein même
de la majorité dans un contexte sur
mobilisation de l opposition et
d'absentéisme et dans le rond à des
marcheurs le vote de ces réfractaires a
failli coûter cher à la république en
marche avec en particulier à l'adoption
de justesse d'un article clé du texte en
tout cas cette possible prorogation du
pass and i ter jusqu'à jeu et 2022 est
bien continue de mobiliser dans la rue
en quelques gilet jaune se sont réunis
aux abords de l'assemblée nationale afin
de protester de contester ce projet de
loi il réclame le retrait pur et simple
de se passer ni terre considérée comme
liberticide 1 pour la plupart une
mobilisation statique qui s'est achevée
vers 19h et david sat et chef de la
commission mixte paritaire ombre donc
désormais la voie à un nouvel examen du
texte
effectivement et ce don selon le
ministre de la santé et bien il ya une
recrudescence des cas on parle même
d'une cinquième vague le ministre la
santé appelle à la vigilance la reprise
épidémique se confirme en france et
commence à se faire ressentir à
l'hôpital selon les données publiées ce
soir par santé publique france 6000 à
680 personnes sont hospitalisées en
raison d'une infection au co vite ses
ailes quarantaine de plus acquis hier à
1091 personnes sont en soins critiques
et 75 personnes sont décédées du virus
ces dernières 24 heures à noter
également que le taux d'incidence
nationale est environ de 57 cas pour
100000 habitants en augmentation de 11 %
sur les sept derniers jours olivier
ferrand insiste donc sur la nécessité de
ce pass sanitaires pour lutter
efficacement contre le virus mais aussi
et sur les gestes barrières à respecter
à noter que la france prend du retard
sur la vaccination complète et des
personnes âgées d'où l'inquiétude de
l'exécutif
merci beaucoup david khalifa en direct
depuis l'assemblée nationale épidémie
repart comme l'affirment donc jean
castex cet après midi la tendance est
mauvaise et que dire du reste du monde
où l'épidémie a galope déjà 5 million de
morts selon l'om est-ce qu'ils jugent
elles mêmes le chiffre sous-estimé se
seraient deux à trois fois plus de décès
selon l' oms alors y at il un risque de
cinquième vague doit-on craindre un
nouveau confinement ce serait le pire
décryptage avec un aux invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir sur ce
plateau alexis poulain éditorialistes
darty france bonsoir alexis merci d'être
avec nous en duplex le docteur alex
endoctrine laurent alexandre est
chirurgien et céistes docteur alexandre
vous êtes l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages
bonsoir à vous à vos côtés arnaud chiche
anesthésistes réanimateurs vous êtes le
fondateur du collectif santé en danger
merci à tous les trois d'être là alors
on va commencer par le point sur la
situation pas très brillant puisque la
tendance épidémique et est mauvaise je
me propose tout d'abord de jeter un oeil
sur ces chiffres publiés par santé
publique france 1866 cas supplémentaires
en 24 heures ce sont les données de 2
lundi 1er novembre soit hier six mille
six cent trente neuf personnes
hospitalisées
un peu plus de 2000 personnes 1000 69
précisément en réanimation ce n'est pas
une flambée mais chaque jour ça monte un
peu plus nous dit jean castex ça veut
dire qu'on va pas échapper à la
cinquième vague docteur laurent
alexandre comme le prédit olivier
ferrand
on peut craindre effectivement une
vaguelette mais pour l'instant les
chiffres qu'on a sont plutôt rassurants
par rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière on est toujours en dessous de 2
200 morts 150 morts par jour en moyenne
on n'a pas l'explosion à laquelle on
assiste en ce moment en russie 1 qui
n'arrivent pas à descendre en dessous de
1000 morts par jour on a une
augmentation des contaminations qui est
relativement logique parce qu'on
al'impression les épidémiologistes ont
raison que ce virus est en train de
devenir un virus saisonnier en tout cas
d'acquérir des comportements de virus
saisonnier il y a une augmentation qui
ce qui arrive à l'automne et nous avons
aujourd'hui une courbe qui ressemble un
petit peu à celle qu'on avait il ya un
an mais avec une différence c'est
qu'elle est retardée par rapport à
l'augmentation
enregistrée à partir de fin septembre
début octobre 2020 et puis surtout on a
un nombre de or qui est beaucoup
beaucoup plus faible donc par rapport au
cours de la dernière on a un ratio mort
par nombre de gens contaminés qui est
moins élevé donc oui on risque d'avoir
une vaguelette ou une petite vague non
il est peu probable qu'on ait mille
morts par jour comme on a pu l'avoir à
certains moments lors des vagues
précédentes
donc il faut faire attention mais
personnellement et peut-être que je me
trompe je suis beaucoup plus optimiste
pour cette année que pour l'année
dernière faut pas oublier par exemple
convient de dépasser 88 % d'adultes
vaccinées en france et dans les pays
comparables alors ce n'est pas suffisant
pour stopper les contaminations et on
sait bien que la protection du vaccin
contre les formes mortelles est très
forte mais elle est moins forte sur la
transmission donc il faut faire
attention mais je ne crois pas qu'on va
vers un confinement généraliser une
nouvelle fois on va relativiser donc les
propos du gouvernement on en reparlera
d'ailleurs de cet aspect politique dans
quelques instants avec alexis poulain
mais d'abord arnaud chiche le premier
ministre a également évoqué la pénurie
de personnel soignant qui frappe de plus
en plus fort sur fond de fatigue
évidemment auprès de 18 mois de crise
les soignants serait prêt en cas
d'afflux de nouveaux patients dans les
hôpitaux
écoutez vous mettez là le doigt
justement sur le gros problème c'est que
comme l'a dit le docteur alexandre
effectivement la situation n'est pas
différente cette année il ya une
vaccination qui a été fait mais le
problème c'est que comme il n'ya pas
d'anticipations de l'état de l'hôpital
et comme on n'a pas anticipé de toute
façon depuis cette première crise
qu'ovide le fait que le ségur ne
suffirait pas pour donner envie aux gens
de rester à l'hôpital on se retrouve
aujourd'hui alors qu'on n'a pas de pic
épidémique dans une situation s'était en
france catastrophique et donc en fait ça
veut dire que si on considère admettons
qu'on a encore 20 % de patients non
vaccinés je peux vous affirmer ce soir
que ces 20% là s'ils peuvent suffire à
paralyser le système sanitaire donc je
suis d'accord avec le docteur alexandre
il ya normalement devrait pas avoir de
problèmes de confinement mais tout est à
mettre en regard de notre état sanitaire
et l'état sanitaire aujourd'hui ces
fermetures de services d'urgence
fermeture de chou mur manque de lit
partout et forcément si jamais il ya le
moindre petit afflux de malades ce sera
tout de suite la paralysie alors dans
les hauts de france les chiffres
augmentent un peu y'a pas il n'y a pas
de ya pas de pic mais ça augmente on a
tous un peu des patients comme dit dans
nos établissements il est très difficile
de le prévoir parce qu'on ne sait pas
très bien chez la population vaccinée ce
qui va se passer en n'a pas vraiment de
donner là dessus donc on a du mal à
prévoir
l'afflux chez les patients vaccinés
parce que comme on vous l'a très bien
dit ça diminue très fortement le risque
de kobe de grave mais ça ne réduit pas à
zéro non plus donc en fait on a du mal à
savoir ça mais ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
sait c'est que si on n'anticipe pas
l'afflux possible des patients non
vacciner à l'hôpital ça va être la
catastrophe voilà les soignants sont
épuisées il manque de lit partout vous
entendez parler de la bronchiolite en ce
moment bon ben ya pas dix pour les
enfants donc autant vous dire qu'il y
aura pas de 10 pour les corridas ça va
être le même problème donc très vite on
va être en plan blanc si ça va pas très
vite on va devoir faire de la
déprogrammation la déprogrammation qui
est devenu un peu le juge de paix de
l'adaptation des hôpitaux c'est à dire
qu'en fait on arrête d'opérer les
malades pour dispatcher le personnel
normalement alloués à la chirurgie à
l'accueil de ces patients là et je vous
parle aujourd'hui de services d'urgence
ferme un peu partout en france ou alors
tu ne ferme que la nuit et comme vous le
savez le cowitz entre 9h et 17h c'est
jamais la nuit car assurant en tout cas
côté politique députés et sénateurs on
le disait alexis poulain s'écharpent sur
la prolongation du passani terre propose
d'écouter philippe bas
échec de la réunion des députés et des
sénateurs dans la recherche d'un accord
sur le pass sanitaires le président et
le gouvernement refuse que le parlement
se prononce en février pour décider s'il
ya lieu de continuer à restreindre les
libertés pour combattre le coc vide elle
que le gouvernement lui on veut
prolonger le pass jusqu'au 31 juillet
les sénateurs veulent lui l'arrêté en
février et revotés ensuite philippe bas
c'est quand même pas n'importe qui c'est
l'ancien général secrétaire général de
l'elysée il dit que ce terme un
continuer à restreindre les libertés
pour lutter contre le coc vite qu'est ce
qu'il entend par là alexis poulain est
resté un des libertés tout simplement on
voit bien que ce pass sanitaires il est
pas anodin et le problème c'est que le
gouvernement fait tout pour qu'il
devienne anodin qu'il devienne
finalement un élément de la vie
quotidienne ça ne doit jamais être le
cas parce que on est en train de renier
les libertés l'air de rien finalement
mais il ya un projet derrière qui est le
contrôle social qui est le contrôle des
populations et là il n'y a pas de raison
d'empêcher les parlementaires de revoir
la clause de revoyure en février je ne
vois pas pourquoi le gouvernement ne
voudrait pas le faire c'est qu'il a peur
c'est qu'il a peur qu'on arrête ces
mesures là parce que ça l'arrangerait de
pouvoir enjamber la présidentielle avec
ce pass sanitaire qu'elle est là quelle
est la raison en fait de ne pas vouloir
avoir un rendez vous démocratique
emmanuel macron depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire gouverne de manière
antidémocratique il gouverne or sous le
sceau du secret défense en conseil de
défense en ayant fille à la fois des
avis du conseil économique social et
environnemental des assemblées et même
des conseils qu'il a autour de lui en
impression que rappelez-vous au début de
la crise était vraiment lui qui décide
est allé au théâtre à nantes puis
finalement je vais vous confinés pendant
un mois on est en guerre mais mon le
masque bah c'est bon l'improvisation ça
suffit on en parlait avec le dr chiche
il n'y a aucune vision par rapport à ce
qu'on peut faire pour arrêter en fait
l'improvisation et prévoir que ce soit
une vaguelette ou une vague mais qu'on
ait une planification sanitaire
aujourd'hui de passe il n'est pas
sanitaire c'est un passe simplement pour
dire on va encore pousser les français à
la troisième dose parce que certains
rechignent à voir cette troisième
barroso allait bien sûr ben oui donc il
est là pour ça même s'ils ne veulent pas
le dire et la réalité c'est que vous
avez toujours des populations qui sont
loin et du vaccin et du pass et on
continue de creuser des différences au
sein même de la population française il
n'y a pas de raison le pass tanit est
rappelez-vous au début de la crise
macron dit il ne sera jamais utilisée
pour les activités du quotidien et
maintenant on veut le prolonger jusqu'en
juillet sans même avoir de clause de
revoyure alors qu'il devait finir le 15
novembre c'est à dire dans même pas dix
jours donc c'est n'importe quoi à un
moment il va falloir vraiment un
contrôle parlementaire on voit bien que
la vème république aujourd'hui
défaillante que les contre-pouvoirs sont
défaillants et que aujourd'hui la
gestion de crise elle est le fait d'un
seul c'est emmanuel macron et laurent
alexandre de vous vous vivez se passer
ni terre comme levier alexis poulain
comme une restriction des libertés ou un
mal nécessaire
alors non je le vis pas comme une
restriction des libertés j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir une quelconque une
diminution de mes libertés il ya en
france et en belgique et de sortir on
téléphone portable et aimons passe je
n'ai pas l'impression que c'est une
restriction de la liberté je me suis
dépêché d'aller faire ma troisième
injection et je n'ai pas l'impression
d'être ni en belgique ni en france dans
un enfer dictatorial je remarque juste
mais à l'ex icône m ma position là
dessus que ce qu'il vient de dire sur le
gouvernement dans la plupart des pays
authentiquement démocratique
l'entraîneur est en prison demain matin
ce qui ne sera pas le gain alexis a le
droit de critiquer le gouvernement ce
qui prouve qu'on est quand même pas dans
une dictature à la chinoise et je ne
citerai pas ici d'autres exemples de
pays légèrement autocratique donc oui il
y à il ya un vrai problème sur la durée
du passé et j'en conviens bien je fais
plutôt partie des gens qui pensent que
ce serait pas mal qu'il y ait un nouveau
vote du parlement en février mais j'ai
pas l'impression d'être dans une
dictature j'ai beaucoup critiqué la
stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement y
compris sur votre antenne au premier
trimestre 2001 je ne suis toujours pas
en taule on ne m'a toujours pas envoyé
en camp de rééducation
franchement je n'ai pas l'impression de
vivre en europe de l'ouest dans une
horrible dictature pour revenir sur ce
que disait alexis à propos du bordel
français de la difficulté à régler la
crise regarder ce que font d'autres pays
merkel était considérée comme une heure
un génie des carpates de la gestion de
la crise y est un homme regarde les
chiffres actuels ils sont extrêmement
mauvais les chiffres dérape on continue
en allemagne merkel a admis son échec
ces derniers jours son échec partiel
même s'il n'ya pas énormément mort grâce
à la vaccination il ya un an deux cas
très élevé donc je crois que nous devons
nous médecins c'est la preuve d'une
humilité on a du mal dans cette guerre
virologique à nous projeter et à faire
de bonnes prévisions et on a dit
beaucoup de bêtises on a dit beaucoup de
conneries donc nous devons faire une
crise d'humilité les gouvernements
doivent écouter l'opinion edwards
et là je suis d'accord avec alexis doit
faire des passes sur des périodes
limitées c'est pour ça qu'il serait bon
qu'il y un nouveau vote au printemps
mais on on ne peut pas aller jusqu'à
dire qu'on vit dans un horrible régime
dictatorial je pense que je pense qu
alexis exagère quand il dit ça en tout
cas ce n'était pas du tout mon becali ça
j'ai pas dit qu'on vivait dans un régime
dictateur jeudi que le pass ne doit pas
devenir un pass du quotidien le problème
c'est s'habituer à cette mesure là qui
est une mesure exceptionnelle va donner
la parole quand même arnaud chief
pardonnez moi ça c'est passionnant ce
que vous racontez messieurs mais
rarement chez jeffrey d'envoi les
paroles aussi justement
mais globalement c'est plutôt pour
appuyer les propos de excusez moi ce
qu'on appelle en même temps c'était pour
appuyer appuyé les propos du dr
alexandre effectivement malgré l'amitié
que je porte aussi à alexis poulain il
faut bien rappeler une chose
je suis désolé mais faut bien rappeler
une chose il faut bien rappeler il faut
bien rappeler une chose c'est que si les
gens se vaccine n'y a pas de problème
avec le pass annie terre donc ça c'est
le message envoyé on doit se faire
vacciner ah lalala lalala
et j'essaye de classe une dernière chose
effectivement
non mais on vous entend alors à vous
m'entendez oui donc en fait
effectivement il faut faire preuve
d'humilité parce qu'on a déjà été
surpris et je suis un peu surpris que
justement on n'anticipe pas une
difficulté à venir sur un terrain
sanitaire déjà en difficulté moi ça ça
mais frey et finalement quand on entend
ça moi qui encore le pass annie terre ça
me rassure un petit peu parce que quand
on dit ouais il faudra tu ne passeras
unitaire on joue un peu au caïd on joue
au poker on fait comme si on avait un
système de santé hyper robuste mais le
système de santé c'est un c'est un
château de cartes aujourd'hui et il peut
s'écrouler donc moi je dirais aucun
enseignement de cette pandémie en tout
cas sûr du point
non papa la hauteur fallait hop à la
hauteur de ce qu'il aurait fallu madame
non non aucun aucun aucun parce qu'en
fait la seule chose qu'on entend
aujourd'hui c'est que le ségur de la
santé a été fait or aujourd'hui on
assiste à une hémorragie de soignants et
une fermeture d'audi partout en france
et l'état est sourd au fait que le ségur
est insuffisante
c'est bien tout l'argent du ségur mais
les gens s'en vont donc en fait là il
faut faire en urgence un plan qui va
permettre de garder les soignant à
l'hôpital il faut faire des packs de des
packs de fidélité quand ils sont là
longtemps il faut faire des pas grand
âge quand ils travaillent dans des ehpad
il faut il faut vraiment fidéliser cette
population de soignants qui est encore
là a redonné ma seconde mais le fait que
certains soignants ne se soit pas fait
vacciner est ce que ça a pesé non ce que
vous nous décrivez oui il ya quelques il
ya quelques exemples effectivement de
services en difficultés
il ya quelques exemples de services en
difficultés à cause de soignants qui
finalement dû arrêter de travailler mais
il faut pas il faut pas stigmatiser là
dessus ça représente pas énormément de
monde mais ça existe quand même il ya
certains services qui sont en difficulté
à cause de ça mais c'était déjà des
services qui étaient déjà très fragile
alors si vous enlevez deux personnes
d'une équipe de 6 forcément il reste
plus grand monde à la fin donc c'est pas
ça le vrai problème le vrai problème
c'est le terrain sous jacent et quand on
n'aura pas compris dans ce pays en
pleine période présidentielle qu'il faut
s'emparer du sujet santé en urgence
absolue le climat c'est important
l'éducation la justice c'est important
mais comment voulez vous qu'on parle
d'éducation et de protection climatique
si on n'est pas capable d'opérer les
gens de traiter les cancers et d'envoyer
le smur pour quelqu'un de 30 ans ou 35
ans du fer l'infarctus doc simulé on est
dans une gestion de pénurie est là et là
et là on réfléchit un petit peu à ce qui
peut se passer avec le co vide mais le
problème c'est que le terrain de base il
est très très très fragile et moi je
voudrais insister là dessus ce soir
alors pas ciani terreur voter oui
probablement ce pas trop mon domaine
mais oui je vois pas pourquoi on
pourrait pas leur beauté progressivement
mais aujourd'hui l'état des hôpitaux est
tellement fragile que le passé annie
terre c'est une très bonne chose et puis
encore une fois quand les gens se
vaccine et ben ma foi la vie comme
dirhams docteur alexandre moi aussi je
montre mon je monte mon téléphone est
finalement
on préférait on préfère réquier pas ça
mais faut quand même pas exagérer c'est
pas l'enfer en tout cas au niveau
planétaire l'épidémie galope 5 millions
de morts officiels recensés par l' oms
qui considère que c'est sans doute deux
à trois fois plus un en russie notamment
le président poutine a appelé la
population à se faire vacciner un
millier de morts par jour en russie un
docteur alexandre en parlait il ya
quelques instants à moscou la
correspondance de maylis d'extrait
vladimir poutine a chargé ce lundi le
ministère de la défense de soutenir la
population civile dans la lutte contre
la pandémie notamment en participant à
la construction d'hôpitaux temporaire le
président a également rappelé que la
vaccination reste le meilleur moyen de
se protéger contre le coc vide c'est la
vaccination qui sauvent réellement d'une
évolution sévère de la maladie et d'une
issue létale actuellement des
médicaments sont en cours de
développement et j'en suis sûr seront
utilisés dans un proche avenir
aujourd'hui j'en ai parlé également avec
mes collègues avec ceux qui travaillent
là dessus pourtant le meilleur et le
plus universel des moyens de se protéger
et de se faire vacciner d'après le
kremlin la situation actuelle représente
une surcharge de travail extrêmes pour
les médecins et ne s'améliorera pas dans
les prochains jours des propos confirmés
par l' agence fédérale sanitaires
l'effet obtenu grâce aux mesures qu'on
est en train d'adopter et qu'ils le sont
déjà ne se fera pas ressentir
immédiatement
il faut du temps pour cela au moins une
période d'incubation est nécessaire très
probablement il faudra plus de temps il
n'a ainsi pas exclu que la semaine chômé
actuellement en vigueur dans toute la
russie soit prolongée dans plusieurs
régions celles de novgorod nord ouest de
moscou à d'ores et déjà pris une
décision en ce sens mesqui peskov le
porte parole du kremlin a rappelé que
chaque région est libre d'adopter des
mesures supplémentaires comme le pass
sanitaire si la situation locale
l'exigent
selon le plan d'action énoncés dans le
décret présidentiel correspondant
jusqu'au 7 novembre inclus nous avons un
régime de jours chômés au niveau fédéral
dans le même temps le plan d'action du
kremlin suggère que toutes les régions
disposent de pouvoirs spéciaux pendant
la période de la pandémie et en fonction
de l'évolution de la situation
épidémiologique peuvent prendre des
décisions de manière indépendante dans
le contexte de leur région particulière
enfin il ne faut pas croire les rumeurs
il faut se fier aux informations
officielles
au milieu de toutes ces mesures une
lueur d'espoir toutefois aujourd'hui le
nombre de nouveaux cas est repassé sous
la barre des 40 milles avec un peu plus
de 39 milles contamination reste
désormais à voir si cette tendance se
confirme dans les prochains jours alors
guère rassurant ce qui se passe en
russie laurent alexandre ça veut dire
quoi qu'en france on peut aussi avoir
des surprises
et qu'il va falloir en arriver à cette
fameuse troisième dose pour justement
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
mauvaises surprises
alors le problème de la russie c'est pas
la troisième dose c'est la première dose
pour l'instant donc le taux de
vaccination russe il est extrêmement
faites vous le savez on a dépassé les 25
% il ya très peu de temps et on voit
bien que il faut un taux de vaccination
à peu près du triple du taurus pour
avoir une protection correcte et la
comparaison entre la russie et les pays
comme la france montre bien qu'il ya une
vraie protection avec la vaccination
alors aujourd'hui l'urgence pour pour la
france c'est pas tant la troisième dose
même si je suis tour et même si moi j'ai
pris la troisième dose pour moi c'est de
faire la première et la deuxième dose
pour les quelques millions de personnes
qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés et
notamment quelques centaines de milliers
de gens de plus de 80 ans qui ont un
risque très élevé de mourir s'ils font
écho vide et qui ne sont pas vaccinés
donc il faut se concentrer d'abord sur
la première et la deuxième dose de nos
aînés les plus fragiles où le taux de
vaccination n'est pas de 100 % ce qui
est absolument inacceptable et ce qui
est très très dangereux puisque on sait
bien qu'il ya 180 fois plus de chances
de mourir quand on fait un coded est con
et seniors que quand on est jeune donc
la vraie priorité c'est de finir de
vacciner nos grands parents alexis cette
troisième dose elle passerait mal auprès
des français certains oui clairement on
leur a promis de le retour à la vie
normale avec le vaccin rappelez vous
c'était la promesse initiale ont là à ce
moment là même ce retour à la vie
normale bat pas vraiment puisqu'on parle
de vaguelettes d'épidémie on a le pass
sanitaires on a les gestes barrière qui
n'en finissent pas le masque qui revient
dans les écoles dans 39 départements
donc non on n'est pas dans la vie
normale et on a l'impression qu'on y
sera jamais donc là la première promesse
elle est tombée à l'eau et là on nous
dit avec la troisième dose promis cette
fois ci au printemps prochain peut être
à l'été prochain ça y est on va
retrouver la vie normale évidemment que
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide les
français se disent une dose de doses
trois doses et puis quoi encore et puis
on a des pays où on parle déjà de
quatrième dose pour certains cas avec
des comorbidités ou des publics déjà
affaiblies donc on sait pas en fait si
ça va marcher si quelle est la durée
d'ailleurs de protection du vaccin
contre les formes graves on attend à des
retours d'expériences encore on a même
des fabricants de vaccins qui vous
disent on ne sait pas quelles peuvent
être les effets secondaires à long terme
on ne sait pas on ne peut pas vous dire
on attend de voir le patron de modern
acquis 10h12 interview au parisien je
peux pas vous dire pourquoi il ya des
myocardite chez les plus jeunes on le
sera peut-être dans quelques années
c'est pas très rassurant pourquoi on ne
serait pas là dans les mois qui viennent
pourquoi ya pas d études des recherches
pour éviter justement même s'ils sont
peu nombreux ces effets secondaires donc
il va falloir vraiment un moment
rassurer les français 10 rebonds vous
faites la troisième dose elle est sans
danger faites-la et voilà mes mais
clairement il ya des populations pour
qui n'ont 2 ça suffit la troisième
bonjour les dégâts voilà merci en tout
cas alexis poulain merci docteur laurent
alexandre d'avoir été avec nous
également mercier arnault schiste qui
nous a quittés donc il ya quelques
minutes merci à tous les 3es en tout cas
il n'y a pas qu'en france un contrôle
des réfractaires au vaccin je voudrais
qu'on traverse l'atlantique à new york
la vaccination est obligatoire pour tous
les employés municipaux et ça passe mal
chez les pompiers notamment les
explications de notre correspondant
d'air et internationales quel est mon
pain
le maire de new york bill de blasio a
mise en application l'obligation
vaccinale pour les pompiers de la ville
les pompiers refusant de se faire
vacciner de même que d'autres employés
munci hôtel que les policiers les
ambulanciers serait immédiatement mis en
congé sans solde
cette décision est entre en vigueur et
le bilan est mauvais natko à
se jouer demi pompiers de l'état de new
york sont en congé sans solde
d'après la représentante
nicole ou un agneau takis membres du
parti républicain
il semblerait que 26 caserne de pompiers
new yorkaise est dû fermer suite à cette
décision accélérée
dans tous les cas c'est un nombre
important et cela a des conséquences sur
la sécurité des new yorkais à ce jour
cinq mille policiers du nypd en déposer
une demande de sanctions afin d'essayer
de continuer à travailler malgré la
décision du maire de new york à ville de
blasio et des manifestations contre
cette obligation du lieu dans toute la
ville dont de nombreux employés
municipaux c'est une insulte ils se
mettent en péril ils risquent leur vie
pour protéger la population contre le
crime contre les incendies pour sauver
les personnes
et il mérite la dignité de pouvoir
choisir ou non de se faire vacciner les
tribunaux de l'administration municipale
cependant ne sont pas de cet avis de
segré et malgré les manifestations et
malgré les protestations des
travailleurs crus sont les travailleurs
essentiels ont été mis en congé sans
solde c'est un moment important selon
les sondages ces obligations vaccinales
sont impopulaires alors même que la
plupart des américains des new yorkais
sont en faveur de la vaccination
le scepticisme vis-à-vis de ses
obligations vaccinales et du message
envoyé aux travailleurs essentiel de new
york est assez répandue
boris johnson restent prudemment
optimiste sur les chances de succès de
la coop 26 à glasgow le premier ministre
britannique qui salue tout de même une
nouvelle initiative pour préserver les
poumons de la planète
aujourd'hui plus de 100 pays se sont
engagés enrayer la déforestation d'ici à
2030 un engagement remis en question par
certaines ong amaya soul et
la préservation des forêts mesure phare
de ce deuxième jour de la coop 26 ce
mardi à glasgow une centaine de pays
s'engagent à mettre fin à la
déforestation d'ici 2030 ils
représentent tous ensemble 85% des
forêts mondiales parmi les pays on
retrouve le brésil la russie ou encore
l'indonésie souvent pointé du doigt sur
la déforestation de leurs espaces
naturels ce projet sera porté par un
financement public et privé de plus de
19 milliards d'euros
les forêts sont importantes pour moi car
elle couvre plus de 60 % de mon pays
elles sont source de santé de vie et
abrite les plus grandes richesses
naturelles et la plus grande
biodiversité de la planète nous nous
sommes engagés à éliminer la
déforestation illégale d'ici 2030
j'appelle tous les pays à contribuer à
la défense de toutes les forêts
notamment en y consacrant des ressources
suffisantes pour qu'elle profite à tous
vbck ont récolté dacquoise
pour global witness ong qui lutte contre
la déforestation
si le nombre de signataires de ce nouvel
accord est inédit la mise en oeuvre de
ces engagements est plus complexe je
pense qu'il ya un certain degré de
scepticisme quant aux engagements mais
comme je les dis ce qui est vraiment
important c'est qu'ils ont signés et
j'espère qu'il y aura un déclic et que
nous pourrons utiliser cet élan mais le
problème avec beaucoup de ses
engagements c'est que les gens ne sont
pas tenus responsables les gouvernements
ont pris des engagements similaires en
2014 avec la déclaration de new york sur
les forêts mais n'ont pas permis de
réaliser les progrès escomptés
autre engagement mis sur la table
l'émission des gaz à effet de serre
cette fois plus de 80 pays dont l'union
européenne et les etats unis se sont
engagés à les réduire de 30% d'ici 2030
cette mesure concerne le méthane
puissant gaz à effet de serre et
permettrait de ralentir immédiatement le
réchauffement climatique selon la
présidente de la commission européenne
le premier ministre indien à rennes
drame audi a de son côté annoncé à la
surprise générale une neutralité carbone
pour 2070
l'inde qui est le troisième plus gros
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre au
monde avait jusqu'ici refusé de
s'engager sur le sujet
et on l'évoquait la russie qui
s'engagent aussi donc pour la protection
de l'ensemble des forêts de la planète à
cette occasion le président vladimir
poutine fait une déclaration en marge de
cette coop 26 la correspondance à moscou
de bérat goffman
la dmr poutine a soutenu le projet de la
déclaration conjointe sur les forêts et
la gestion des terres présenté lors de
la réunion de la cop16 à glasgow le
président russe ne s'est pas rendu sur
place mais envoyer un message vidéo aux
participants la dîmière poutine a
souligné qu' environ 20 pour cent de
toutes les forêts du monde se trouvait
en russie que les autorités prenaient
les mesures les plus sérieuses et les
plus vigoureuses pour les préserver je
vous propose d'écouter
la russie soutient le projet de
déclaration conjointe sur les forêts et
la gestion des terres présenté pour
approbation lors de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui est
la chute je réalise et nous espérons que
sa mise en oeuvre encouragera une
coopération plus étroite entre tous les
pays intéressés à la sauvegarde des
forêts odile ce billy joel et saufs
s'amenuise ceci contribuera sans aucun
doute à réaliser les objectifs de
réduction de co2 dans l'atmosphère s'est
fixé dans l'accord de barils
lors de son intervention vladimir
poutine a réitéré l'ambition russe
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone vers
2060 déjà renoncé lors de son discours
au sommet du g20 à rome dimanche
rappelons que la conférence sur le
changement climatique réunit
actuellement en grande-bretagne en
écosse plus de 120 dirigeants du monde
entier
ngoc 26 marquée par le retour les états
unis à la table des discussions dont
washington qui à nouveau rejoint les
corps de paris après un retrait de
donald trump son successeur joe biden
veut lui prendre une autre direction le
président américain doit annoncer
d'ailleurs dans les prochaines minutes
une série d'actions pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique on retrouve
notre correspondant thomas bonnin en
direct de washington
bonsoir thomas joe biden qui va donc
reprendre à la parole de manière
imminente puisqu'il a déjà parlé hier il
avait d'ailleurs déjà promis beaucoup de
choses à son arrivée à la maison blanche
pour quel résultat pour le moment en
tout cas
est bien assez peu de concret finalement
dans les propositions et dans les
actions entreprises par joe biden depuis
qu'il est arrivé à la maison blanche on
sait que c'était un thème de campagne
très important pour le candidat
démocrate à l'époque puisque cela le
différencier de façon assez notable de
donald trump qui avaient des positions
très différentes sur le climat aura donc
eu beaucoup de promesses de la part de
joe biden sur la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
je vous propose d'écouter justement
cette opposition de style entre le
candidat joe biden et le candidat donald
trump c'était donc au mois de septembre
joe biden n'est pas un ami de la
pennsylvanie il est d'ailleurs pour les
raisons qu'on vient d'évoquer votre pire
cauchemar by john a soutenu chacune des
attaques mondialistes sur les
travailleurs de la pennsylvanie l'accord
de libre échange nord américain l'entrée
de la chine dans l'organisation mondiale
du commerce qui a permis à la chine de
devenir une puissance
l'accord de partenariat transpacifique
la corée l'accord horrible et ridicule
de paris sur le climat qui a privé notre
nation de son énergie et le soi-disant
clean power plein si on donne un
pyromane du climat quatre années de plus
à la maison blanche comment pourrait-on
s'étonner que l'amérique s'embrase
encore davantage si nous donnons un
climato sceptiques quatre ans de plus à
la maison blanche comment pourrait-on
s'étonner que plus de régions d'amérique
soit sous l'eau
va donc pour les positions radicalement
opposées deux anciens candidats à la
présidence elle est d'ailleurs lorsque
joe biden est arrivé à la maison blanche
l'une de ses premières mesures a donc
été de réintégrer l'accord de paris sur
le climat est un acte plutôt symbolique
suivie de la présentation d'un plan
d'investissement d'envergure pour là
encore lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
un plan qui a été revue et corrigée
depuis parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de blocage au congrès l'a
encore été modifiées est la semaine
dernière et joe biden aurait sans doute
espéré que ce plan soit adopté au
congrès avant qu'ils ne se rendent à la
coop 26 à glasgow mais ce n'est donc
toujours pas le cas les négociations
vont toujours bon train au sein du
congrès américain avec encore des
discussions et des négociations qui se
déroulent à l'heure où je vous parle
alors malgré tout joe biden veut se
positionner à la pointe de ce combat
contre le réchauffement climatique sur
la scène internationale au mois de
septembre dernier déjà il y avait une
réunion virtuelle
en amont de cette coop 26 et joe biden
avait appelé les dirigeants du monde
entier à prendre la mesure des enjeux se
servant alors des différentes
catastrophes naturelles qui se sont
déroulées ces derniers mois et coûté au
cours des deux dernières semaines j'ai
voyagé à travers les états unis et j'ai
pu constater les dégâts et les
destructions causées par les ouragans
les inondations et les feux de forêt la
chine continue à travers excusez moi le
climat continue à changer à travers
l'europe l'afrique et l'amérique latine
vous avez enduré des inondations
massives des incendies ont fait rage en
australie en amazonie et dans la toundra
rue chicago
et c'est donc là toute l'ambivalence de
la position de joe biden comment peut-il
convaincre à l'international alors
qu'ils peinent déjà à rassembler dans
son propre camp sur ces questions là aux
états unis certains dénoncent aussi une
forme d'hypocrisie entre les paroles et
les actes du président américain puisque
rien que dimanche dernier il a notamment
appelé à augmenter la production
mondiale de pétrole en soulignant lui
même le caractère ironique de sa
déclaration mais en rappelant qu' à
l'heure actuelle les pays du monde
entier étaient encore tributaire des
énergies fossiles beaucoup soulignent
aussi le cortège de 10 zen de voitures
qui accompagne le déplacement du
président américain et ce y compris lors
d'un sommet pour le climat comme c'est
le cas de la coop 26 à glasgow et puis
parce que les images sont aussi plus
forte que certains un discours beaucoup
ont partagé la photo et les images de
joe biden assoupis pendant un discours
lors de cette coop 26 une image qui a
finalement plus circuler que les propos
du président américain merci thomas
bonnet vous restez avec nous s'il vous
plaît puisque on va aller plus loin avec
notre invité qui nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau général de olivier bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste franco américain
chercheur à l'institut de prospective et
de sécurité en europe thomas venait d'en
parler cette petite sieste ans dont on a
vu les les photos un petit peu partout
sur internet au moment où une personne
d'ailleurs sur scène a précisé justement
l'importance de prendre des décisions
sur le climat voilà on peut y voir une
métaphore de la triste réalité le
décalage souvent entre les discours des
chefs d'état est là et la réalité oui on
y voit aussi d'asie donc et fatigués qui
est un petit peu âgées et puis à une
certaine le saut moyen et long voyage
été nommé fin voyage remonte à jeudi il
a eu il est arrivé à rome où wade a pas
mal d'activités non mais ça tombe très
mal votre reporter a parfaitement raison
votre correspondant à washington a
parfaitement raison c'est une c'est une
image qui a été reprise par les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'elle fait sourire alors
elle fait sourire d'autant plus que joue
pour joe biden ce sommet est très
important il faut rappeler qu'il l'a
préparé il l'a préparée au mois d'avril
et encore une fois votre journaliste à
washington avait raison de rappeler
qu'il aurait beaucoup voulu venir avec
des munitions et ses munitions c'était
ces fameuses enfin les deux lois qui
sont en attente est en discussion devant
le congrès parce que dans ces lois il y
à un certain nombre de fêtes qu'il fasse
un certain nombre de choses qui vont
venir pour justement participer à la
transition énergétique américaine et a
priori diminuer leur empreinte carbone
et augmenter leur recours aux énergies
non fossiles or il est il est venu les
mains vides et il s'endort pour la
journée d'ouverture donc l'image est pas
très bonne alors effectivement jobs n'a
d'ailleurs qui s'exprime en ce moment
même qui a dévoilé une série de
réglementations vivement vide en visant
pardon à réduire nettement les émissions
de méthane un de l'industrie pétrolière
et gazière aux états unis mais les états
unis c'est toujours la même question à
ce qu'ils sont vraiment prêts à sortir
de cette dépendance de d'énergies
fossiles et du pétrole en tout cas en
tout cas est ce qu'ils sont prêts alors
il ya deux façons de répondre est ce que
je veux dire idéologiquement ou
émotionnellement est ce qu'ils sont
prêts et est-ce que techniquement ils le
sont il n'y aurait pas la même réponse
actuellement le renouvelable c'est 12 %
de l'approvisionnement énergétique
américain le solaire ce doit être un
pour cent et le l'éolien 3% donc on est
alors que 67% c'est du fossile donc
remplacer deux tiers de votre
approvisionnement énergétique pas
quelque chose qui pour l'instant
totalise 4 % votre approvisionnement
c'est pas du tout évident à faire du
jour au lendemain donc sur ce point de
vue là il est évident qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts ensuite les états unis sont une
puissance en matière d'énergies fossiles
et sacrifié cette puissance sans savoir
ce qu'il y aura derrière c'est quelque
chose qui politiquement est beaucoup
plus difficile à faire et politiquement
on en parlait d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
mais à thomas en attendant effectivement
comment il perçu ce ce rendez-vous de la
coop 26 aux états unis comme l'a bien
décrit gérald olivier c'est vrai que
mentalement et techniquement les états
unis sont pas forcément prêts à sortir
de leurs leurs vieilles dépendance si
j'ose dire
oui c'est d'ailleurs un peu l'opposition
qui faisaient déjà fois lors de la
campagne présidentielle entre joe biden
et donald trump puisque la question des
emplois liés à ces énergies fossiles et
est souvent abordée par donald trump
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
l'ancien président américain qui parlait
aux travailleurs de pennsylvanie on sait
que c'est un un état où il ya une
production de pétrole notamment mais
vous avez d'autres états comme la
virginie occidentale qui est très riche
en charbon et le sénateur qui bloque
aujourd'hui l'adoption au congrès du
plan d'investissement sur le
réchauffement climatique notamment de
joe biden c'est le sénateur jim en chine
les élus en virginie occidentale et s'il
refuse notamment d'adopter ce plan c'est
parce qu'il sait que cela pourra avoir
un impact sur l'économie de l'état dans
lequel il est élu et donc il ya toujours
cette question des emplois qui est mise
en parallèle avec la question évidemment
de l'écologie même si on sent qu'il ya
une progression dans l'opinion de
l'importance accordée à ces questions
puisque des récents sondages ont montré
que désormais elle 59% des américains
interrogés considéré comme très
important la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique alors qu'en 2018 à seuls 49%
des américains se disaient très soucieux
de cette question générale de viviez
vous le disiez donc blocage aussi sur le
plan évidemment politique qui suit les
mentalités américaines les républicains
qui bloquent souvent on l'a dit tout est
lent mais aussi parfois les démocrates
oui oui mais c'est bien la question et
va encore une fois votre votre
journalisme parfaitement résumé la
situation
aujourd'hui les démocrates ont la
majorité à la chambre des représentants
s'il voulait voter cette loi il pourrai
faire demain à condition d'avoir la
garantie qu de tous voté dans le même
sens c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et en
plus au sénat ils sont à 50-50 avec les
républicains et ils ont deux sénateurs
qui rechignent pour deux raisons
différentes à voter ce plan monsieur
monde chine pour les raisons qui
viennent d'être évoqués et madame cinéma
qui est sénatrice de l'arizona et qui
elles rechignent plus tôt sur le point
de vue des taxes qui pas des impôts qui
inévitablement suivrait cette loi est
comme elle est dans un état où les
électeurs n'aiment pas beaucoup payé des
impôts eh bien elle ne veut pas vous
voter une loi qui inévitablement va
aller les augmenter donc on a des
discussions au sein même du parti
démocrate et les républicains n'ont pas
à être opposés à cette législation parce
que de toute façon c'est le camp d'en
face qui n'arrivent pas à s'unir et tant
qu'ils ne seront pas unis ne se passera
rien thomas est ce que c'est populaire
de lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique
aux etats unis c'est pas exactement la
première question parce qu'effectivement
il ya sept ce style de vie sains
merrick inquiets pas toujours en phase
vraiment avec l'environnement on le sait
oui de toute façon l'économie à une
place évidemment très importante pour
l'opinion américaine est dès lors que
des emplois risquent d'être menacés il y
a une position je lisais par exemple des
témoignages de syndicats de travailleurs
du charbon ou du pétrole qui explique
qu'ils aient bien par exemple il ya john
kerry qui demande à ses employés de
changer de voie peut être de se
reconvertir pour travailler pourquoi pas
dans la fabrication de panneaux solaires
et ses gens expliquent qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément l'envi de se reconvertir dans
d'autres secteurs et qu' il ya aussi
peut-être moins d'argent qui leur sera
accordé donc il ya un aspect économique
qui est très important d'ailleurs joe
biden qui est connaît très bien la
pennsylvanie avait beaucoup parlé de cet
aspect là lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle pour tenter justement de
rassurer tous les travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui dépendent à 100% de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
des énergies fossiles mais il ya encore
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et ses
inquiétudes elles sont évidemment
majoritaire pour les personnes qui sont
concernées et plus globalement pour les
localités les états où sont basés les
exploitations de ressources fossiles
j'adore olivier quand je parlais du mode
de vie des américains c'est vrai que
voilà qui a été aux états unis se rend
compte est toujours frappé les grosses
voitures individuelles la climatisation
alors on sait que joe biden pousse dans
le sens de l'électrique m'enfin ils
poussent pas dans le sens des transports
eau comme un bon quand on connaît les
intérêts us est aussi très compliqué
parfois de faire en métro toutes ses
distances mais tout de même est ce que
c'est compatible avec ces grandes
annonces oui plutôt dépend d'où vient
l'électricité électricité peut très bien
venir du charbon donc même si quand on
utilise à l'arrivée c'est non polluants
au départ ça reste peu allemand et ça
reste quelque chose qui qui qui émet des
gaz de serre il ya eu une petite
évolution des mentalités aux états unis
il ya aussi une évolution du style de
vie américain qui est quand même un tout
petit peu moins gaspilleur qui le fuit à
une trentaine ou une quarantaine
d'années mais qui reste quand même basé
sur une consommation assez je dirais
peut contrôler on va dire mais surtout
ce qui se passe aux etats unis c'est que
même si certains sont prêts à faire des
efforts pour la planète ils ne sont pas
prêts à sacrifier la prospérité
américaine pour sa 1 et 2 ils ne sont
pas prêts à faire des efforts si
d'autres ne le sont pas et rappelons qu
à glasgow nous avons la russie qui est
absente nous avons la chine qui est
absente en tout cas en terme de leurs
dirigeants principaux et nous avons
également le brésil qui est absent de la
russie qui a pris comme des
désengagements même titre que les autres
mais
je ne sais pas parce que c'est une
chaîne russe que je défends mais il faut
rendre à césar
mais malgré tout la russie est une
économie qui dépend de ces énergies
fossiles qui dépend de son gaz naturel
et de son pétrole donc ça c'est un point
très important la chine c'est un pays
qui consomme énormément d'énergie
aujourd'hui et qui est le créateur et
plus c'est bien ainsi que les états unis
voilà 27 % des émissions de co2 dans le
monde proviennent de la chine c'est deux
fois et demie ce que les etats-unis
produisent aujourd'hui et puis vous avez
le brésil qui est le premier en termes
de déforestation et on n'en parle pas
assez de la déforestation mais rappelons
que les forêts servent aussi à capter du
co2 et que quand la déforestation
progresser bien en voix inévitablement
des température qui monte des
précipitations qui tombent une
désertification qui avancent donc cet
anneau de sujets dont on pourrait pour
le parler plus est au moins autant que
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour conclure gérald olivier clairement
pas seulement un coup de communication
ce soir il y aura des actes selon vous
suite à cette comme 26 alors c'est la
deuxième chose qui est très importante a
remarqué c'est que monsieur byden même
président des états unis peut faire un
certain nombre d' annonce à partir du
moment où il ya un finance un
financement derrière c'est le congrès
qui contrôlent donc il a promis par
exemple de débloquer 3 milliards de
dollars cuisant pour les pays africains
pour compenser leurs pertes dans la
transition énergétique mais si le
congrès n'est pas de son côté et si le
congrès ne signe pas pour libérer les
fonds il pourra pas les donner donc il
ya une limite à ce que le président
américain peut annoncer non thomas
d'ailleurs nous expliquer combien il
était parfois compliqué de négocier au
congrès merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington merci n'avoue gérald olivier
sur ce plateau d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci
et dans les coulisses de cette coop 26
paris et longtemps de désamorcer la
crise post break 6 sur la pêche en vain
pour le moment la position britannique
ne change pas selon boris johnson ce
soir les discussions doivent donc se
poursuivre puisque paris a décidé de
repousser ces mesures de rétorsion et
sanction qui devait entrer en vigueur
aujourd'hui reportée à jeudi en toile de
fond la délivrance des licences de pêche
dans les eaux britanniques et les
menaces que de l'est
un bras de fer en suspens londres et
paris n'ont toujours pas résolu leurs
vieux différend sur la question de la
pêche avec les négociations qui
s'étendent londres obtient un répit
paris menacé le royaume uni de mettre en
place des sanctions dès ce lundi minuit
prévoyant d'interdire les navires de
pêche britannique de débarquer leur
cargaison dans les ports français un
ultimatum qui se voir porter au moins
jusqu'à jeudi où doit se tenir une
réunion
ce n'est pas pendant qu'on négocie qu'on
va mettre des sanctions on verra où on
en est demain à la fin de la journée
pour savoir si les choses changent de
nature les prochaines heures sont des
oeuvres importantes j'ai compris que les
britanniques allaient revenir vers nous
demain avec d'autres propositions un
espoir côté français d'une inflexion du
royaume uni mais dimanche encore le
premier ministre britannique a affirmé
que leurs positions restaient inchangées
paris également continuent de réclamer
que toutes les demandes de licence faite
par les pêcheurs tricolores soient
satisfaites le compromis semble encore
compliqué d'autant que la menace de
sanctions brandie par le gouvernement
français irrite les britanniques les
français se sont comportés de manière
injuste ce n'est pas ce que prévoit
l'accord commercial et si quelqu'un se
comporte de manière injuste dans le
cadre d'un accord commercial vous êtes
en droit d'y répondre et de demander des
mesures de compensation c'est ce que
nous ferons si les français ne font pas
marche arrière
londres riposte et menacent de déposer
une plainte pour non respect de l'accord
commercial qui lie les deux pays autres
actions possibles contre paris le
renforcement des contrôles des bateaux
de pêche européens une mesure qui
entraverait fortement les relations
commerciales avec l'ensemble de l'union
européenne
au centre du contentieux
l'accord debré exit que les deux parties
s'accusent de ne pas respecter sur selon
le texte les pêcheurs européens peuvent
continuer à travailler dans certaines
eaux britanniques à condition de pouvoir
prouver qu'ils y pêchait auparavant mais
londres et paris s'écharpent sur la
nature et l'ampleur des justificatifs à
fournir face à l'impasse les deux pays
appelle bruxelles à l'aide pour jouer
les médiateurs pour des négociations qui
s'annoncent ardues
et outre la pêche autre passe d'armes
entre paris et londres elle concerne
l'alliance britannique avec les états
unis et l'australie dans l'inde au
pacifique un conflit qui aboutit sur
l'annulation par canberra d'un
méga-contrat les australiens s'étaient
engagées à commander des sous-marins à
la france pour un total de 56 milliards
d'euros théo combat
comme 26 ou givors le premier ministre
australien scott morrison et emmanuel
macron participe depuis une semaine aux
mêmes événements internationaux millet
de gouvernance évite soigneusement
depuis septembre dernier et la crise
provoquée par la rupture australienne du
contrat qui prévoyait la livraison de
plusieurs sous marins français pire les
deux hommes sont à couteaux tirés depuis
le camoufler nouvelle preuve ce lundi je
ne souhaite pas personnaliser cette
affaire il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
de mon point de vue je dois dire que je
pense que les déclarations qui ont été
faites remettant en cause l'intégrité de
l'australie il les insultes qui ont été
proférées à l'encontre de l'australie
pas contre moi j'ai les épaules larges
je peux faire face à cela mais ces
insultes je ne vais pas les tolérer au
nom de l'australie je ne vais pas les
tolérer au nom des australiens scott
morrison fait ici référence à l' échange
entre un journaliste australien et
emmanuel macron le 31 octobre dernier en
marge du g20 questionné sur l'honnêteté
du premier ministre australien sur le
dossier des submersibles le président
français s'est montré explicite
pensez vous qu'il vous a menti je ne
pense pas je le sais
des déclarations qui contredisent les
informations relayées par la presse
australienne affirmant que scott
morrison aurait déjà évoqué le sujet de
la rupture du contrat en juin dernier
puis le 13 septembre deux jours avant
l'annoncé officielle un argumentaire qui
rappelle celui de joe biden lors de sa
rencontre avec emmanuel macron lors du
g20 à rome
le locataire de la maison blanche avait
affirmé penser que le gouvernement
français avait été informé de longue
date de ce revirement de situation
un désaccord sur les faits qui pousse le
poids ministre australien a repoussé la
normalisation des relations avec paris
l'australie sera heureux de travailler
avec la france sur des projets d'intérêt
mutuel je pense qu'il est clair d'après
les déclarations du président macro hier
que le niveau d'eau france est encore
très grand et nous attendrons que cela
s'appelle
ironie du sort c'est devant un chantier
naval que le premier ministre australien
a fait ces déclarations en pet comme 26
le dégel des relations diplomatiques
entre les deux pays ne semble
visiblement pas d'actualité avant de
longues semaines
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du nouveau dispositif du
gouvernement français pour répondre à la
précarité des moins de 26 ans sans
formation ni emploi le contrat
d'engagement jeunes l'enveloppent
pourrait aller jusqu'à 500 euros par
mois dispositif coûteux de plus aux
mesures au rabais le débat est ouvert
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
sictom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien depuis c'est pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique de désintéresserait en lieu
et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme si
son travail en notre nom pour nous est
dans notre intérêt à tous
le résultat dangereux peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
les ong sont devenus en 50 ans des
acteurs incontournables de la société
moderne par leur impact auprès des
gouvernements et du public confondant
régulièrement les grands principes avec
leurs objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le ratio
le sectarisme de la majorité d'entre
elles les amènent à des interprétations
qui exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
condition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le contrat d'engagement jeu
nouveau dispositif du gouvernement
français pour répondre à la précarité
des moins de vingt six des 26 ans sans
emploi ni formation l'enveloppent pourra
aller jusqu'à 500 euros par mois à
condition sinequanone 15 à 20 heures par
semaine de formation ou d'accompagnement
alors ce contrat d'engagement jeunes
dispositif coûte de plus en mesure au
rabais le débat est ouvert et les avis
divergent vous pouvez toujours réagir
sur le compte un télégramme verte et
france
accompagné au moins quatre cent mille
jeunes en 2022 c'est donc objectifs du
gouvernement
sur un contrat d'engagement jeunes
déclaration cet après midi de jean
castex pour compléter l annonce du
nouveau dispositif des manuels mais cran
alors que prévoit ce contrat pourquoi
est il critiqué éléments de réponse avec
nicolas petit
ils sont parmi ceux qui ont été les plus
pénalisés depuis le début de la pandémie
les jeunes précaires est impacté par la
crise auquel macron avait promis des
aides en juillet dernier annoncé pour la
rentrée
c'est finalement ce mardi que le chef de
l'état on a détaillé les derniers
contours concrètement dès le 1er mars
tous les jeunes de moins de 26 ans qui
sans formation ni emploi depuis
plusieurs mois s'inscriront pourront
bénéficier de 15 à 20 heures
d'accompagnement par semaine pour
découvrir un métier se former trouver un
apprentissage ou un emploi une
allocation pouvant aller jusqu'à 500
euros par mois pourra être versée sous
conditions de revenus d'assiduité et
d'acceptation des offres d'activités
fait désireux de ne pas associer cet
accompagnement à une allocation de type
rsa adapté aux jeunes l'exécutif a donc
préféré opter pour un contrat basé sur
l'assiduité du côté de l'opposition ces
annonces ont surtout de quoi interpeller
la mesure est valable uniquement 2022 on
a un président qui ne se soucient pas du
long terme il fait campagne avec le
chéquier de la france tous les jours et
ça c'est insupportable
le comble d'une farce cru elle pour les
jeunes peut-être 500 euros si 20 heures
d'engagement 5 euros de l'heure lancée
en mars et ça existe déjà en deux à l'oc
la macro ni est un paradis artificiel
tout temps comme au même titre que le
candidat france insoumise à la
présidentielle les associations et
syndicats étudiants estiment que le
compte n'y est pas alors qu'au mois de
juillet le chiffre d'un million de
jeunes ciblés par ce nouveau dispositif
avait été avancé jean castex à ce mardi
déclaré qu'au final seulement 400 milles
le seront en 2022
alors le contrat d'engagement jeunes une
réponse adaptée vraiment à la précarité
des moins de 26 ans d'échecs à tout va
pour séduire à six mois de la
présidentielle ou dispositif coûteux de
puces ou aux mesures au rabé on attend
vos réactions sur le comté d g berthet
france place à notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler léon de fontaine
secrétaire général du mouvement des
jeunes communistes et porte-parole de
fabien roussel bonsoir aliments de
fontaine merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés jack smith délégué national uni
union nationale inter-universitaire
bonsoir à vous aussi léon de fontaine
est ce que cette mesure elles répondent
déjà à une réelle urgence les moins de
26 ans ils sont de plus en plus dans la
précarité après cette pandémie l'urgence
est là mais cette mesure n'y répond pas
aujourd'hui on nous donne cette offre on
propose 500 euros par mois et après ses
quinze heures de formation et après ces
bonnes chances et on attend que jeunesse
se passe or emmanuel macron nous avait
promis quand il était candidat moncef
merveille et au final on se retrouve
avec une garantie jeunes réchauffer au
micro ondes avec 2 euros 50 de plus par
mois or ça ne répond pas du tout
aujourd'hui aux besoins et aux
aspirations des jeunes loin de là on est
complètement à côté et je pense qu'on
attendait autre chose du président des
jeunes malheureusement il ne va pas plus
loin il le pourrait mais il ne va pas
plus on va aller évidemment plus loin
dans le débat c'est l'objet de ce face à
face mais sur le diagnostic déjà l'ex
miss il ya vraiment urgence pour les
jeunes leur situation s'est empirée avec
avec la pandémie il fallait agir mais il
est clair que là ce qui est sûr c'est
que la crise a été en effet engendré une
crise sociale chez les étudiants qui est
qui et qui est clair aujourd'hui de
nombreux de nos après les nombreux ce
successifs
confinement on a vu que quand on faisait
nos distributions alimentaires nombreux
sont les étudiants qui venaient donc
effectivement il ya clairement à une
crise sociale chez les étudiants
aujourd'hui et cette mesure elle vient
elle vient un peu alors peut on a
consulté très peu les les organisations
étudiantes elle vient en fait un peu
comme un cheveu sur la soupe et qui est
en fait un rsa jeunes camoufler et on
ouvre le carnet de chèques à six mois de
la présidentielle aujourd'hui les
étudiants ils n'attendent pas une
allocation de 500 euros par part moi ils
attendent surtout qu'on les aide dans
leur insertion professionnelle et
surtout un travail à faire leurs études
parce que la première leurs études parce
que la première précarité aujourd'hui
c'est s'aider jane c et malheureusement
de chômage à la fin de leurs 2 lors de
leur formation universitaire alors lyon
de fontaine vous disiez voilà le compte
n'y est pas c'est vrai que emmanuel macm
ans est souvent présentée comme le
président voilà des jeunes un jeune une
solution il ya eu la garantie jeunes
annoncé en juillet dernier là c'est quoi
c'est la garantie jeunes qui disparaît
au profit
de quelque chose de moins bien on a des
ambitions revues à la baisse on a des
ambitions revues à la baisse par rapport
aux annonces qu'avait fait emmanuel
macron en grande pompe il me semble 14
juillet au discours du 14 juillet aux
alentours du 14 juillet en revanche la
garantie jeune césar on est complètement
dans la continuité de la garantie jeunes
en réalité on vient créer un nouveau sas
de précarité avant l'entrée du marché de
l'emploi or aujourd'hui ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est travail et
aujourd'hui faute d'ambition politique à
la hauteur et ben emmanuel macron
propose un nouveau contrat jeunes comme
l'ont fait ses prédécesseurs on avait eu
le cpe on a vu d'autres mesures aucune
de ces mesures n'a fonctionné pire elle
a aggravé la situation de précarité dans
laquelle se trouvait la jeunesse est
aujourd'hui en effet le compte n'y est
pas aujourd'hui moi je suis représentant
d'une organisation de jeunesse on est
tous les jours devant les lycées sur les
universités et les jeunes nous disent
nous on aspire à deux choses c'est
trouver des études pour être accepté
dans la fière de son choix et après
trouver un emploi qui ait un sens qu'ils
soient utiles et qui nous permet de
vivre dignement et on n'a pas besoin
d'un nouveau contrat précaire ce qu'on
veut nous c'est un emploi correctement
rémunérés et les jeunes ne demandent que
ça et ça tombe bien on en a besoin
aujourd'hui ouais ça veut dire en gros
comme on subventionne des jeunes sans
leur offrir de d'emploi vraiment vous
êtes sûr au moins peut-être sur cette
même ligne chaque smith alors ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette mesure
elle et elle est clairement c'est un
effet de communication de la part du
gouvernement emmanuel macron le
président et être est un expert en la
matière et donc aujourd'hui en fait cela
c'est pour ouvrir tout simplement encore
une fois à six mois de la présidentielle
le carnet de chèques c'est un chèque en
blanc il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup de flou
autour de cette de cette aide qu'est-ce
qui sera en contrepartie de ces 500
euros la formation ou est-ce que elle
sera donnée ça sera sûrement
dans les missions locales on nous a dit
ouh ouh le pôle emploi mais aujourd'hui
effectivement le gros gros problème
c'est l'insertion professionnelle en
2020 vous savez durant la crise
sanitaire il ya eu un gros problème
d'insertion pro après un bac + 5 donc un
master 2 en france il y a eu la moitié
des étudiants qui rentrait son match de
travail qui était encore au chômage au
bout de six mois donc ça c'est le réel
problème des jeunes aujourd'hui et
manuel mckee on arrive n'arrive pas à y
répondre et ça c'est une certitude les
premiers messages l'on parvienne à
ginette rechapés gaspillage d'argent
l'apprentissage est déjà en place ça
c'est vrai que c'était une des grandes
critiques de la journée l'es11 de
fontaine notamment de la droite et cette
dame c'est vrai qu'on ouvre le carnet de
chèques comme le dit jacques smith à
quelques mois de la présidentielle il ya
un petit peu de ça aussi où vous le
ressentez pas comme ça de l'argent il en
faudra ça c'est sûr pour permettre aux
jeunes de se former sans devoir ce
salariat côté leurs études de pouvoir
aller le plus loin possible dans leur
formation ça c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui en effet par contre cette
aide c'est de l'argent jeté par les
fenêtres nous ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on
revendique c'est la création d'emplois
et aujourd'hui on a un besoin de
l'emploi on en a besoin dans le service
public notamment l'éducation la santé on
l'a vu pendant la pandémie ou le manque
de personnel s'est fait durement
ressentir on en a aussi besoin dans le
privé pour réindustraliser le pays
relancer le pays mais aujourd'hui encore
une fois bah oui l'argent est mal
orienté l'argent en fait on ne sait pas
où va le gouvernement
nation quelle formation si les
formations c'est les mêmes qui sont
proposées actuellement par les missions
locales
aujourd'hui les missions locales nous
dit tout en fait pour l'instant
on a du mal à les alpaguer les jeunes à
aller chercher les jeunes parce que les
jeunes il ya un taux de non recours est
en fait la réalité c'est que l'on
connaît un certain nombre de jeunes qui
ont fait le plein un jeune une solution
par exemple eh bien on leur offre une
formation en attendant parce qu'on ne
sait pas quoi leur dire afin de les
sortir des chiffres du chômage
aujourd'hui ça ne répond pas aux besoins
ni la population ni à celui des jeunes
l'index mix pour vous c'est pas très
adapté non plus est cette solution parce
qu'on nous parle toujours des emplois à
pourvoir notamment de rendre dans le
secteur de la restauration
de l'hôtellerie on a toujours du mal à
comprendre quand on est en tout cas
observateurs comme en voilà ces deux
camps entre guillemets ne se rencontrent
pas mais cette mesure c'est toujours
plus de dépenses publiques sans réelle
efficacité en fait c'est toujours la
même chose effectivement et on l'a dit
c'est en fait ce que françois hollande
l'ancien président avait mis en place
avec garantie jeunes c'est juste une
garantie jeunes un peu un peu plus large
un peu plus développé mais on voit bien
françois hollande socialiste donc c'est
une mesure réellement de gauche est
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron ne répond
pas au problème de la précarité et de
l'insertion professionnelle aujourd'hui
il faut clairement développé largement
les contrats d'apprentissage pousser les
entreprises aussi en ces temps de crise
sanitaire et donc sociale et donc sur le
marché du travail pour rentrer pour en
étudier aujourd'hui c'est compliqué donc
pousser les employeurs à
l'ajustement prendrait employés les
jeunes qui rentrent sur le marché de
travail et notamment se demandent 30 ans
en lui en essayant de leur alléger les
charges fiscales et patronales tous la
cdc des cdc des solutions que nous
propose que l'uni propose depuis
longtemps mais vous savez quand vous
avez une ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur qui a du mal déjà à parler
juste de à dire texto insertion
professionnelle on voit bien que que ils
ont pour priori plus priorité de de
faire un chèque en blanc de deux
d'offrir de l'argent à tout va et ce
quelques quelque chose en fait qui ne
résout pas réellement la crise 2 de
l'entrée de sur le marché du travail
pour pour un jeune aujourd'hui très
véronique qui nous dit une arnaque à la
hauteur du reste du quinquennat de la
com pour les présidentielles mais on
sent que ce n'est pas une femme laide
emmanuel macron nécessairement il ya
quand même du bon lait en de fontaine
dans cette mesure notamment ce peut être
un autre introduction des droits et des
devoirs c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
mesures ou là on l'envisagé au début de
subventionner sans retour là il ya
vraiment quand même des obligations
c'est quelque chose qui nous semble
juste
non non je pense que c'est un problème
de voir les choses comme ça aujourd'hui
on vient sa mesure elle laisse
sous-entendre que si aujourd'hui il ya
un jeune sur cinq au chômage c'est parce
que il serait pas adapté au marché de
l'emploi et qu'il faudrait les reformer
et cetera non aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui
à un jeune sur 5 près d'un jeune sur
cinq au chômage c'est parce que
justement nous n'avons pas d'emplois et
donc avant tout il faut mettre une
politique en faveur de la création
d'emplois comme j'ai dit dans le service
public et je pense que dans le privé il
faut conditionner aujourd'hui on donne
des milliards d'euros à des entreprises
sans conditionner ses aides nous ce
qu'on propose c'est de conditionner ses
aides à l'embauché de jeunes en cdi et à
la formation professionnelle
et aujourd'hui ça paraît aberrant que ce
ne soit pas le cas aujourd'hui on donne
des milliards ça c'est des vrais chèques
en blanc on donne des milliards à des
entreprises sans aucune condition
d'embauché de jeunes en cdi et donc ça
fait des effets d'aubaine aujourd'hui on
embauche des jeunes en cdd 3 mois et ça
permet derrière aux entreprises dans une
entreprise de toucher de l'argent public
et donc de nos impôts et ça c'est
scandaleux jacques smith vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que dit léon diouf en
tête aujourd'hui le vrai problème et
vous vous vous en avez parlé c'est
l'orientation quand vous avez et il faut
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un manque
clairement de réformes structurelles de
fond est que ces petites mesurettes sont
inutiles et inefficaces aujourd'hui il
ya un manque de réformes structurelles
de fond qui sont qu' il faut prendre du
recul le gros problème aujourd'hui les
jeunes c'est l'orientation après quand
vous avez un baccalauréat qui a une
heure à taux de réussite à près de 95%
qui n'est plus du tout un passage en
entrée à une entrée un examen d'entrée
dans l'enseignement supérieur mais
justin c'est un pseudo certificat de fin
d'études
quand vous avez la moitié des étudiants
de première année de licence qui soir
double soit se réoriente quand vous avez
en france une possibilité de pouvoir
avoir un bac + 3 sans avoir passé une
semaine dans l'entreprise quand vous
avez encore une fois ce taux de horrible
de 55% près de 55% de bac + 2 master 2
d'une université qui sortent bac + 2
d'universités françaises qui sont encore
au chômage au bout de six mois ça c'est
des choses qui sont qui c'est la réalité
c'est des choses qu'il faut régler est
ce qui n'est absolument pas en donnant
500 euros par mois sans contrepartie ou
presque qu'il faut qu'on règle contre
partie injuste non parce que encore une
fois ça sera dans les missions locales
déjà il va falloir les créneaux dans ses
missions locales et donc ça sera pas
fait tout de suite donc c'est une vaste
arnaque et puis encore une fois ces
formations elles ne sont jamais abouti
ça a été dit jamais très peu de jeunes
ont pu être formé et trouver un emploi
grâce à ce genre de glace à ce genre de
vous qui n'êtes pas au plaisir oui je
dis enfin il ya un problème
d'orientation aujourd'hui c'est certain
surtout qu'on oblige les jeunes à se
sélectionner à s'orienter beaucoup plus
tôt notamment dès la 3e mais aujourd'hui
le premier problème on l'a vu c'est la
sélection à l'entrée de l'université et
la précarité étudiante aujourd'hui s'il
ya autant d'échecs à l'université c'est
parce qu'on a un étudiant sur deux qui
est obligé de se salarier à côté de ces
études est à côté qui est obligé d'aller
faire la queue devant des organismes de
distribution alimentaire et nous on a
une mesure concrète là dessus c'est la
création d'un revenu étudiants au dessus
du seuil de pauvreté pour tous les
étudiants pourrait sortir de cette
précarité un revenu sans contrepartie un
revenu sur la contrepartie c'est
d'étudier voilà c'est la réalité en
réalité l'ambition c'est la voie la
jeunesse la mieux formée parce qu une
jeunesse formée c'est celle qui sera
capable de répondre aux défis que nous
avons devant nous et lui n'y est bien
d'accord et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
regarder ces allocations avec avec du
recul et vous devez être bien bien
content de ce2 ce2 de cette mesure
puisque en fait ce n'est qu'un rsa
jeunes camouflé alors certes qui n'est
pas aussi large et qui ne touchent pas
autant de d'étudiants que vous voudriez
mais c'est clairement toujours plus de
dépenses publiques avec toujours moins
d'efficacité et donc c'est clairement
quelque chose qui va dans votre sens et
qui ne va pas dans une meilleure
orientation des étudiants et des jeunes
et une meilleure insertion
professionnelle et c'est ça le vrai
problème et c'est la première précarité
des jeunes c'est ne pas avoir de
bouilloire
un succès 91 mille lycéennes et lycéens
bacheliers qui n'ont pas été acceptées
dans l'enseignement supérieur si ce
n'est pas une sélection à grande échelle
je ne vois pas ce que c'est et c'est ce
que vous vous proposez et pour le coup
ça remplit les un million et demi de
jeunes qui se retrouvent sans emploi des
formations directement et ça vous pouvez
pas dire que c'est une mesure que nous
nous portons au contraire c'est une
mesure que vous défendrez depuis mai
avec 95% de taux de réussite du bac vous
savez ce n'est plus une entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur promenade c'est
un pseudo certificates fardé de d2
d'études secondaires qui ne veut plus
rien dire et donc aujourd'hui quand vous
pouvez quand vous voyez la stat 2 de la
moitié de dna à la fin de l'heure et
lakic issoire double soit se réoriente
il y a un gros problème d'orientation il
faut clairement tapé là dessus que le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
prennent en charge cette problématique
merci en tout cas sous les 2 ex miss à
léon de fontaine d'avoir accepté ce face
à face et avant de nous quitter à je
voudrais lancer cet appel à témoigner à
vous qui nous regarde et vous avez moins
de 26 ans justement vous avez
l'impression que le gouvernement ne
répond pas à votre précarité vous ne
rentrez pas dans les cases écrivez nous
à l'adresse qui s'affiche sur votre
écran qu'en pensent les français qu plf
@ rt tv.fr et si vous avez d'autres
histoires des témoignages à nous
raconter pas que sur ce sujet de la
précarité étudiante n'hésitez pas pour
être éventuellement en témoignage dans
cette nouvelle rubrique depuis le début
de l'année donc qu'en pensent les
français
cette adresse qui s'affiche donc merci à
vous
et pour finir nouveau chapitre
aujourd'hui du procès des attentats du
13 novembre 2015 après les rescapés et
proches des victimes place aux accusés à
la barre cet après midi salle abdeslam
les précisions de katia technique à la
cour d'assises spéciale de paris les 14
accusés présents vont s'exprimer dans le
cadre des interrogatoires de
personnalité avec les éléments
biographiques leur parcours d'enfance et
de jeunesse et ses salles abdeslam qui a
parle en premier depuis l'ouverture du
procès il s'est montré très véhément se
revendiquant combattants de l'état
islamique mais aujourd'hui il soigne son
image avec un discours très policée à
voix basse en gilet chemise grise avec
les cheveux ras et une barbe foisonnante
qui témoigne de sa ferveur religieuse
alors il a décrit à voix basse une
enfance sans histoire une bonne ambiance
familiale l'obtention d'un bac technique
il était plutôt studieux il a exercé
quelques métier réparateur de trains
intérimaire il était aussi gérant du bar
en 2014 de son frère brahim inde et sur
des terrasses avec un parcours de petite
délinquance qu'il réfute des amendes des
excès de vitesse mais aussi une
tentative de cambriolage en 2010 avec
abdelhamid abou oud un des tueurs des
terrasses son ami d'enfance aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le moment du procès
d'aborder la radicalisation mais sa
croyance est toujours aussi forte par
exemple il a traité ces surveillants
déjà de mécréants en réaction à cet
interrogatoire je vous propose d'écouter
m jean reinhart avocat des parties
civiles nous sommes face à mon avis un
personne personne intelligente qui est
assez qu'est caméléon elle a compris que
l'agressivité dont elle avait fait
preuve au tout début des déclarations
intempestives qui tombait à plat n'avait
plus lieu d'être et c'est pour cela que
je crois que il a changé son disque
alors le basculement alors là c'est le
point d'interrogation parce que là nous
avons tous les éléments qui sont
contraires à ce basculement donc ça fait
intéressant un jour de comprendre
pourquoi il a basculé de quelle façon et
avec qui voilà ça ce sera pour plus tard
l'accusé mohamed habré n'y a parlé
également aujourd'hui c'est l'ancien
voisin de salaires des sma molenbeek il
est accusé de l'avoir conduit le 11
novembre 1015 il était présent à
l'aéroport de bruxelles le 26 mars 2016
dans des attentats c'est l'homme au
chapeau après un échec scolaire et
chaque en club de foot il a fait de
nombreux allers retours en prison il
avait une addiction au casino qui était
financé avec l'argent des vols quinze
années de criminalité sans violence at
il précisé autres accusés yacine à tard
le frère du cerveau des attentats
djihadistes présumés morts en syrie
oussama atar et puis également attendues
aujourd'hui farid car cash accusé
d'avoir fourni des faux papiers qui ont
permis à des djihadistes de venir en
europe en partant de la syrie et autre
procès celui de la sphère des sondages à
l'elysée avec nicolas sarkozy convoqué
aujourd'hui comme témoin au tribunal
correctionnel de paris l'ex président de
la république n'aura finalement passé
qu'une heure à la barre parfaitement
anticonstitutionnel et totalement
disproportionnée voilà comment nicolas
sarkozy a jugé la décision du tribunal
qui le force donc à témoigner au procès
de ses anciens proches de l'elysée
l'ancien chef de l'état a refusé de
répondre sur le fond aux questions qui
lui étaient posées et invoquer son
immunité présidentielle
une posture que dénonce jérôme karsenti
avocat de l'association anticor qui
s'est constituée partie civile
je m'inscris complètement aux faux sur
cette interprétation de la constitution
qui est une manière en réalité pour
nicolas sarkozy de ne pas répondre aux
questions que le tribunal est notamment
anticorps souhaité lui poser et c'est la
fin de cette émission rendez vous demain
dès 20 heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de
réagir de commenter de poser vos
questions sur le télégramme d'ayrté
france auchan point sur l'actualité dans
une trentaine de minutes et l'actualité
qui continue donc à toute la soirée sur
arte
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artarit c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois